hello everyone happy monster hunter
Monday's hello yo what's going on what's
up hey this is a new thing we're gonna
be doing for as long as you guys are
interested in it we're gonna be playing
Monster Hunter every Monday with you
with you guys yeah
come come carry us through fights yeah
so we Ben's got a private server over
you just need to join on the session ID
yeah we're playing on ps4 by the way I
think you should make that yes yes want
to play with us I feel free to join this
session ID and then we'll just party up
with you guys and play some monster
hunter oh yeah good time people start
joining in though you and me are gonna
just play a little bit and do some stuff
do some random stuff because we're we
also the weekend happened and everyone
has run rampant in this I'm seeing
people say like oops I accidentally
dumped 40 hours into this video game and
I don't know how it happened yeah y'all
got monster hunted yeah it shows
people's dedication where I've had this
game like for a couple weeks and I'm
like yeah I'm like 50 hours in like I
feel pretty good about it and someone's
like I've already passed I've already
I've already gone past all this but yeah
so we have the this room up you guys can
join in if if we're off in a hunt and
you see some other people posting up
quests hunt with them yeah we can all
hang out so I was I was mentioning it to
you earlier while we were getting
everything set up but over the weekend I
kind of spent a lot of time grinding out
other weapons so we could show more
stuff off if we wanted to and your boy
has I got some cool dual blades now are
just exploding axes and I'm very into
that I got my switch axe upgraded to the
highest part of the tree that it's in
which I'm very excited about
I've also got all my bow is still the
same
we are in the chat by the way yeah we
can see guys he's also gotten into in
the Monster Hunter exactly oh yeah
I've been trying to learn charge charge
blade charge axe charge the charge
weapon for you guys because it's weapon
I've always been kind of afraid to mess
with but I got this this cool Rathalos
version of it and it's pretty fun cool
all right doing some some cool research
on it but I'll stick with the switch axe
for now because I've I've realized over
the weekend that I am actually a switch
at axe main and that was the weirdest
thing for me the room code is right here
yeah room code like I use type that in
ps4 come hang out with us would be a
good time gotta get my login bonus yeah
oh so have you done the horizon zero
dawn stuff yeah okay yeah they don't
have the Eloi armor in yet or the bow
but from what I understand there is a
special Japan only event quest right now
whoa that we can get in if we change our
search criteria and it's for a longsword
and like some samurai armor for your
palico which isn't exactly like it's not
gonna do anything for us because we're
way past the level that it is but it's a
really cool thing where you fight three
great jag races at the same time but
they're all three different sizes yeah
searching for some tracks so if we could
potentially do that if you want to join
up we could all get maybe that could be
our build up for this this first Monster
Hunter Monday
which we can do cuz I got a couple of
optional quests in there there you go I
don't we do that yeah and we can we can
build up to fighting NER NER Gigante as
a group as a group of friends about
together but yeah so how long is this
game well Ben you're good I feel like I
might not be like a good like estimate
of this because if you just rush story
quests which I don't think you can
really do you might be able to finish
quicker than me but I'm doing like all
the optional stuff I'm upgrading my
canteen I'm doing all the like grinding
out for sets I really like I'm I'm gonna
hit a hundred hours during this stream
and I still have story to do you betcha
that's free food that's a free place to
live that's more time to play Monster
Hunter yeah but in ultra my mom's
country so I can't you know what's wild
that I don't really think about very
much coming from the Midwest where they
they have basements and in all other
parts of the world they have faced with
there are no basements in San Francisco
yeah they don't have anything here we
have people are missing out over here
yeah it's real weird I guess it's like
an earthquake thing or something I don't
know the exact science behind it but
yeah alright so yes a post post up of
quests and I'm just here well let's see
I got a lot Oh
oh you've got a Magna Rose sure yeah
let's let's hit that that optimal
farming line and we can we can do that
it's not really a boss fight or a fight
per se it's more of an event do you
let's do it I'm gonna toggle voucher for
this one thank ya so if you're if you
have this if you want to get in jump in
please we have a couple people running
around I saw a fellow switch axe pal
join on your quest here if anyone is
able to
tenacious over here can definitely join
yeah you want to do this
heck yeah get in on this this is just
farming for for fries or magno summer
basically if you want some fries or
macro stuff this is this is it this is
it for you this was made for gaming
forget being shame yeah heck yeah flip
in the basements the dankest part of the
house
I'm all about it here it's all about
attics your what what's happen at ik
your house got gaming attics oh man time
for endgame do work I think we live in
that endgame life I don't think game
life is stopping it's still going
constant forever I'm gonna give it a
couple seconds Steve this dude here will
join I want to give him the chance I
have a bunch of stuff as well Oh King
and Anne are Shannon how are you doing
will this be on the switch not anytime
soon they were kind of talking about it
yeah I mean like they didn't give a hard
no but they were saying that like a lot
of work would have to be done to make it
work and that's not really in the cards
right now so yeah I feel like if
anything maybe we get like a localized
check to make sure no one else is here
if you do get in late you can actually
join in while we're doing stuff too true
okay so yeah we're gonna go because that
other dude unfortunately is too low
level to do this it's fair thing about
buying this nose wondering can you
continue exploring if you finish the
main quest yeah so literally within
starting the game you get to do
expeditions which are just the exploring
parts of the game where you roam around
and find
monsters to fight without any sort of
like time limit or anything it's weird
so you beat the major story 30 hours in
yeah
oh we've diverted the the major crisis
but wait there's more there's a ton yeah
it takes for like 40 or 50 hours I can I
feel like I can safely say to get like
the last zone yeah yeah I mean 40 hours
to get the final zone which is a pretty
good zone yeah it's it's really
looking game we might run into it if we
if we do the near Gigante definitely
will be doing some end game monsters
here yeah alright so here we are this is
yeah it's cool but it's a bit it sounds
good the the other like I keep calling
they're like they're just experiences
they aren't actual fights the ones that
were in like I think it was Monster
Hunter 4 that had the you're like on a
ship that's going through the sand and
like this giant like sand like knocks
your ship over and it's so much better
than this is not very hard yeah alright
so I'm gonna I'm gonna try to hit my in
my optimum path I've done this a lot and
I feel I feel like I know we can split
up if you want just gonna get hit by the
fire because it reminds me yeah so yeah
so that's actually a thing that Monster
Hunter has been doing kind of I guess
not really recently because it's been a
long time since monster hunters have
been doing a thing but they do a lot of
really good crossover stuff and yeah
we're killing it right now but yeah
they're adding the actual like models
for ryu and sakura into the game so the
other cool thing is that if you're like
a male character you can still be sakura
and it's not like locked out from you
see I think yeah I'm Kai was kind of
worried about UI but if it works like
that I'm pretty into it I'll be out
there adding them in you get special
like hadouken animations now and stuff
that you can buy yeah it's real rad
Hecky I love it when people just come
down a mountain and just just like
launch into whatever they're attacking
so good all of the armor already I'm
actually wearing it right now it's
pretty cool it's a good set
I haven't maxed out it's pretty good for
the UM for the last area because it has
a very high defence against fire and a
lot of those boys breathe fire yes some
of the other dragons that I've been
fighting recently it's been really nice
having the fire resistance yeah I know
that much
I was not prepared for one of them
though I don't want to like we're
probably not gonna fight it this show
but there's some real wild stuff some
lag in the stream I don't think we're
dropping anything we can we can look at
it but if it's very possible at
worst-case try lowering the the
resolution on the the transcoder or you
can refresh the page and maybe that'll
help to be out is this game any good
hat-trick yes if you want to do cool
boss fights all the time
and that's just the game like oh there's
so much good streak is talking about the
game sold amazingly well yeah it means
it's real support that they'd like to
see yeah I was you know I'm not I'm not
a huge bobster I were like oh okay yeah
I have never played the previous ones
but after playing this I was like we
hope this gets big because I want this
to be super successful this is really
good and like day of launch everyone on
Twitter was talking about it and every
one of my friends list was playing it
like I think this game is blowing up
yeah and I've seen a lot of people who
are like who are big monster and fans
like really happy it's it's finally
getting it to do it's really great
because capcom has always had this kind
of philosophy where they're like
sir won't do well unless it's on like a
portable platform which makes sense
because it's always done really well in
Japan yeah but they're always kind of
apprehensive about making like a console
version and to see the console version
doing as well as it is makes me really
happy because I feel like this is a good
way for the game ago yeah it's it's a
bit of a I imagine that was a bit of a
gamble for them right because it's like
well you know it does really well in
Japan they're very happy with portable
it's not gonna do well in America it's
maybe just best to just kind of let to
not rock that boat you know and I feel
like they kind of gambled on it with
this one and I'm glad it's paying off
same oh just drop down right into the
player feel really quick and then near
Gigantes gonna show up here in a [ __ ]
so here we go this is actually cool
we'll get to like we'll get like a
primer when you're gurgaon saying maybe
we'll end this dream there you go with
him is this game see of thief's thief's
nope it's not but okay cool game to
dream idea see a thieves but you go to
islands and you fight monsters I'm in
sign me up
combine the two games I like it Sea of
Monsters oh that's not a bad name right
we'll just just ship it out c-can you
farm those oars when he goes through the
great ravine I believe so but I don't
know if they actually drop anything cuz
I don't remember getting any of the
stuff until this event happens I think I
don't think so because I think they want
you to save this this armor set is like
in game it's your first high rank set
you can get it yeah I believe drop that
on him first all right let's do it
oh that was almost oh you're you're
fighting fighting the dude right I am
fighting here I'll be there in a second
I'm over here still farming stuff that I
don't even need yeah i've started like
trying to farm like the
specific like dual blade sets yeah
like okay I need a one that does high
water to image anyone that does
lightning trying to specialize so I can
make oh come on I was right there don't
do this to me a lot of people in the
chat are talking about the PC version it
seems like a big thing a lot of people
are looking forward to I'm excited yeah
I'm I'm more excited like I'm excited to
play it on the PC because it'll probably
run the best there but right so if the
ad like G rank and time for that or if
the ad like monsters I mean we will have
more monsters before that so presumably
it'll just come with them yeah I got I
got you got got you got got I got got
dang see these are this game I mean
they're very they're very different but
I I'd say for me I like I like Monster
Hunter a bit more but I also haven't
played the full version of C thieves so
I can't can't fully compare I feel like
there's something missing from the beta
like there's more like see I wish
there's more Co thieves like weird
everything's just going so fast the the
the one that I'm kind of wearing right
now the odo gamma yeah that's that skin
this dog do the electric squirrel lyrics
were lizard boy it's a good set too
that's got a pretty cool set that I
really like the look of I forgot my
speed sharpening is so high now that I
just have to touch my my whetstone to it
and it's back to full sharpness I love
that alright so we're coming up on the
wall here real quick and then we'll
shift over to shooting canons he's
already run away
and this part kind of sucks you just
have to wait for him to like get near
the thing yeah so you're kind of just
looking for more looking for basically
ooh there's a little section of breakup
here should break that anyway you get
more bonus parts for breaking it yeah
that's pretty good
there we go
yeah Diablos is is a very serious with
the dual blades but it just wait did you
beat him with the dual blades like by
yourself oh yeah that's that's pretty
intense yeah that fights it's it's just
as scary as you think it is that one's
the challenge for sure when I think of
like the milestones that gave me a lot
of trouble it was the first time finding
an Advil yeah definitely
was its there's always kind of like I
keep calling them gear checks because of
like MMO stuff together they're a lot of
like gear check that's the one ah mines
the one my favorite Thunder squirrel
where's the dragon this there's no fall
damage no there's no fall down yeah
you've got very strong thighs in this
video game everyone's got thick thighs
just the thickest thighs rate oh I
didn't realize what cannon I was in I
was like the cannon balls aren't where I
usually are so this part of the fight
that's the monster we were just on and
we've got to basically stop it from
breaking down this wall this has the
potential to be like cooler yeah then
like with other people because they're
all shooting cannons at the same time
when you're doing it by yourself it's a
little boring yeah kind of running
around and like NPCs will reload the
cannonballs but they won't actually
shoot them unless you touch it
which is kind of weird but also this is
the first time you get to hear the
Monster Hunter theme
it was really right when it happens I
keep bringing that up but I really like
it a lot
telluric I said hi will do will do
you'll see Eric tomorrow I'm sure with I
don't know when he's gonna stream but
something it'll be here and it'll be a
good time believe that it's a good giant
pile of slop it's like a really goopy
Godzilla yeah really like the design but
it kind of grows on me yeah it's it's
probably my least favorite monster
design in the game yeah it's definitely
not the best it's a little much but yeah
ooh
it's been restrained now's the time use
that dragon eater I'll try to run down
there and you do it so people see that
and try to get there as fast as I can
all the way that you land when you jump
you just like barely miss it
yeah right oh I think I think I might
have gotten a little too late but oh no
that's fine whatever we'll still finish
this like there's happy that's the theme
that's the thing yeah sort of
it's like the final first part of the
story but then again the game kind of
just keeps going yeah you're in you're
on supposedly maybe the last possible
thing I so I I would think that but
they're also being like you're doing a
good job fighting all these Elder
Dragons but there's got to be something
that's a jeté ting I'm something else
and look guys please please
what else you gonna throw at me it's
like this weird problem of like there's
just too much content in this game why
why are you there's so many things to
fight I need I have other stuff to do
please stop but like I don't mind it at
all a lot of people I'm coming in the
office this morning everyone's on now I
ran out of cannonballs everyone's like
to see you you played a lot of Monster
Hunter this weekend huh and I was like
Hut how'd you know the look I just I
just saw you on Monster Hunter literally
the entire weekend and it tells you how
long someone's been playing for us which
is like Benson playing for eight hours
straight he hasn't gotten up and moved
at all and you're like playstation why
you gotta do me like that
don't call me out please we could try
and put that in yeah just let people
know like hey by the way like we're just
we're just playing
where you won't see any of the story
content I can cure you that much yeah
yeah there well I mean we've we've all
seen nary ghonte from the debate amost
of us yeah does that that will be
happening probably if we get to that
point so I guess that's that's a heads
up but we'll try to be better about that
we're sorry and again if you do want to
join in and go on some hunts with us or
with some other people in the community
we've got our yeah our session ID down
below with you guys so feel free to join
in play with us play with other people
we can all learn and grow together as a
group dude I'm running out of
cannonballs it's okay I'm I'm down here
on the ship already wasting all the
shots get that get that restraint all
right restrained that's the good stuff
that's what we need I'm gonna go hide
down here apparently everything started
shaking too much
do more damage Utah shots I did not know
you can move the cannon
oh really yeah so you you like kind of
slide him up
I just watched tenacious and move the
cannon a little bit and I was like I
didn't even know you could do that yeah
so we could do that that time shot thing
you're moving your thing you got you got
some shots loaded up oh yeah I'm going
I'm gonna do it I'll do it from my side
yeah I don't know if it's doing more but
we did this it's a very easy thing he's
like there's not yeah but it's worth
doing because it gets you it's a pretty
easy way to get it's that entry-level
high level arm yeah you can get like a
very easy entry-level high level armor
which I'm wearing right now oh come on
cool thanks it just grabs everything you
don't even have to go through at all Hot
Tips I learned that one this weekend so
that's really cool if you want to just
pick up all your stuff really quick just
hold X I love to join but your new a
noob that's fine join anyway uh we might
like if you post up a quest and we don't
have anything else we're doing right
just join you and help you through
whatever you're doing yeah there was a
person who was in the on the server who
was only rank 3 yeah so there we want to
just get everyone to to join so that you
guys can just find people to play with
even if you're not playing with us
yeah if you come in you're like guys I'm
having a really hard time with the
Anjanette will you just take time out
and help me I'll pass that might make it
a joke yeah we can help we're help
people get through this Monster Hunter
one way or another okay Tim your your
load times are quicker than mine - I
didn't get a ps4 / oh yeah
so I could technically do it again I
don't need to you though we don't want
to do it on the stream I'm okay
abandoning it that's fair I already got
the gear at this point you're you're
built up whatever if I needed to make
like an on reset with it or weapons set
with it but I don't think I even have
that option for dual blades dang sure
with youtubers like jacksepticeye I'm if
check wanted to sure
hey man jacksepticeye wants to stream
with us more than happy to I think my
girlfriend would literally die happened
he's a good beauty good boy he's a
massive jacksepticeye fan so just just
playing monster hunter with Jack the
other day the other day oh that's good
died on the spot love these tips and
tricks the caning whole Dex yep yeah
just happening all the time you can hold
X this is great we're building a tips
video right here right right here right
live tips video brought to you by the
games monster Mondays GameSpot presents
Monster Hunter Mondays brought to you by
starburst catch it off week what I want
I want this show to blow up I don't want
to become sponsored by Taco Bell
cuz you imagine how great it would be if
we came in every Monday morning with
like a taco 12-pack cuz you can't beat
that TPD value and we just ate 812 tacos
while we're sitting here playing Monster
Hunter that's the dream yeah and then
we'd have to say like no one else can
use this room for like because because
tacos smell if the taco smell yeah I'd
be actually really gross cuz it gets
really warm in here anyway and you
there's you know it gets kind of kind of
betting I gotta get mix with taco we got
some cool gold cards I'm in I accept I
need to customize my guild card I've
been collecting that okay that's all
good
yeah we've been getting more people in
we could check the player list how we
doing yeah Scott join up guys getting
here and if right if you need help with
a quest let us know level one yeah all
right guys we're probably gonna head to
let's look here what monster did I kill
for that switch axe it's a combination
of one of the Elder Dragons and bat
basil Gus if you don't know what it is I
don't know how to pronounce it it's very
terrifying like it's basically a dragon
if they were a bomber jet
okay we got a Rathalos fight Diablos
fight a sea dragon yep we got a lagana
and and odo Garen woof
just a note again no lava lava one I
want I want to say do do that
odo guarantor do that that lavis off
which one one of those two I kind of
want to do the Eau de Guerre and just
because I want my belt still yes I need
the gem from it I might want to do like
I think the lava one I haven't fought
him yet actually he's a pretty cool guy
okay so Garen let's do this
yeah all right let's do it
let's sign up for that quest so this is
more tips please what we do have a
beginner's guide to actually give a
bunch of a bunch of tips so you can go
check that out
oh there's someone someone who's trying
to do the Lagaan eeeh default quest
we'll be able to jump on in that at some
point sure after we do so because I you
know I'm gonna call it we're gonna kill
this Auto Garen real quick yeah well
we're gonna tear your heart up there
isn't gonna be anything left it's gonna
be a mess I'm playing on a regular
PlayStation 4 messed with the X Copy so
I've been hearing that the Xbox one
version just runs better like flat-out
that doesn't surprise me I mean it's a
more powerful system yeah so I know that
the game has a variable frame rate which
makes it a little rough yeah I think in
the beta they were getting about like 45
the quest ID is down here if you want to
join
okay I was pointing it out because I see
some people asking I thought you forgot
your Ventus but I know like when digital
foundry tested the beta they were saying
they were getting up to like 45 around
yeah maybe the final games a little bit
better who knows they I know they're
gonna if they haven't already they were
gonna do a full video comparing all the
versions but it sounds like if you want
like the best performance the X of the X
until the PC version which that'll be
nice I want that but I think the
community is probably gonna be on the
ps4 I imagine so uh a lot of the
hardcore players usually stick with so
many systems I imagine a lot of them are
gonna be on there not to say that there
won't be people playing it on the
expertly I was thinking about the other
day I'm like wow playing playing monster
hunter on an Xbox with an Xbox
controller kind of like it was messing
with my head a little bit well I'll be
doing that when I play on PC or maybe
I'll plug in the same well we'll find a
way to make it work
why does it tell me to go up he's never
up but I mean I always say like just
play where your friends are ya know like
if you have a lot of friends playing on
xbox play they're okay
I've been playing on probably the worst
possible thing to play on from what
everyone's saying and I'm still having a
blast hundred hours in right I think no
matter what you're gonna have a good
time with this game yeah and even even
with those like lower frame rate or
whatever it's not even that bad oh yo
look out for that boy holy cow just got
ran over I managed to avoid him actually
our buddy got oh I see him now he's in
this area another time two rows like in
the menu like checking like my monster
field guide yeah I just got not good god
Oh somebody says will there be enough
people to play with on xbox I imagine so
yeah you're not gonna have a hard time
finding a match at all just that the
game sold 5 million copies already okay
so I think I think you're good
everywhere that's a real gross play sure
and right
wait the Greek eros because I want that
that real cool set hell yeah
god I realize you guys went down so I'm
gonna okay I found some footprints so he
is down where usually is to gamer wants
information on world force which they
have not dude there is no I don't know
if that's gonna happen I don't think I
don't know if that's gonna happen I'm
gonna say probably not it'd be
impressive if though they said that they
are open to the possibility it's just a
lot of work would have to be done to
make it happen so I think they don't
want to say no but the amount of work
that would happen I imagine that it does
happen it will not happen for a very
long time yeah I anything I feel like
that
the switch might get another one of like
the like crossing yeah so that's the
really cool thing about this guy is he
literally just carries around the dead
body oh the last thing or not the last
thing you fought but one of the previous
things that you fought well that was
really hard thing to beat elder dragon
tracks Oh see there you go flesh that
that's the that's the goopy boy that's
the corpse boy oh hello
hot mic that's me they called me hot mic
that's uh I'm not used to that usually
everyone tells us our mics or - yeah
right maybe we finally done it would
become actual cast boys and our we're
always gonna be loud enough now there is
I'm still holding out for that Dark Lord
I really want double-cross on switch to
get poured it over
Oh to the the switch are not ported I
guess localized because it's it's out in
Japan and I almost bought a Japanese
copy just so I could play but I bet that
would actually the the popularity of
this game could maybe encourage them to
do that
here's open Marty bleeding I'm already
dying
okay keep this boy away from me really
quick I'm gonna take a good drink I'm
gonna stop bleeding here in a second oh
cool there we go
I realized that I haven't really been
doing much fighting so I should probably
jump in and actually start doing some
care I'm the kind of person who I see
like the mushrooms on the that lets you
on them through the flip tricks and it's
like don't do this but I wanted but I'm
gonna spend a good 3 minutes trying to
make this happen yeah I just want to be
cool well I mean it's all about style
you know damn I mean fair Zelda does
rule man that has me thinking though
like if you were to combine the
open-world and breadth of the wild with
monster hunter monsters cause monsters
not open-world in that sense and I'm
okay with it I think the game's actually
great the way it is but yo there's
something about that that could actually
be kind of cool just roaming around and
everything is just like stone talus just
like think about like the kind of like
immersive freeform elements of that game
but with like fighting monsters right
yeah it's like Oh like I can use my mag
niece's to launch myself at the monster
or something that'd be real good your
boys getting real messed up it still
smells me it knows I'm here
see you running around I see you jump in
Bob Jones to see one hunts the dragon's
breath the wild would be way more of
them basically yeah
they lick the dragon fight from yeah
make that like the whole game and
there's just like maybe breath through
the wild was monster hunter whole long
oh my god maybe that was the case we
just never saw it coming
I mean if it came on switch you know
they would do like a breath of the wild
like a winger
oh definitely there we go now we're
talking oh you managed to get to the
tail here that tail car there we go
someone was saying that it was like the
best sense one of the best set like if
you combined it with another set I think
that was probably a wrecks but yeah he's
he's trying to say that my armors real
I've been real real blood kind of
weirded out because I've been seeing a
lot of people be like oh sweet Jack's is
one of the better weapons in the game oh
the odo gear sets one of the best sets
in the game I'm like this is all stuff
I'm doing don't don't call me out and
say that like I've been I've been
basically being carried by my gear
choices oh I see I was getting really
self-conscious but to be honest that
might actually be the case are you just
that good man like you you knew about
the meta before anywhere there you go I
was just way ahead of the curve is the
hammer good as a starting weapon
absolutely I'd say yeah it does a really
good job of stunning monsters and all
you really need to do is do the spin
spin move
spin win yeah so that's why he's on me
Oh God that's trying to get a good poke
in there but it did it couldn't get to
it it's all good
yeah I didn't mean to I mean just switch
it over like that that was I was real
rough yep yeah so every weapon has its
own like combos you don't like unlock
combos or anything they're all there
from the start so it's just a matter of
learning the combos I'm learning how to
best should get some speed eating stuff
going on I do really like the people can
join while the quest is going yeah
that's really cool all right
get back here oh we had another person
join you right yeah so a real a real
hunt now we've got four people in
someone says do you craft in this game
oh you craft there's a lot of craft we
wanna crafting since stick back while I
get this bleeding off of me really quick
all right we got a host which axe pal
heck yeah dude switch axes is the jam
I'm all about that I should pull out my
my duel axes at some point I'm super
into the like explosive affinity so
that's the other nice thing about my
armor set is it actually increases your
chance ride it out very good
now there's so many hits happening this
is this is a mess in the best way jump
on him again oh no come on yeah there we
go
I thought about the entire weekend but I
never opened up the options menu I was
too busy hunting I like I try it right
after this fight I literally was like oh
man I heard about that that changed in
the the camera setting and I should
probably do that but I never like I
never found myself like enough downtime
to its if it's just like the old one
like like they're saying it's it's much
better well do it when we get back into
town
yeah yeah alright is that that is a hot
tip there's a very good hot tip I'm just
real lazy and haven't done it yet well
switch jacks is definitely not hard oh
you guys got the tail carp shoot yeah
yeah Oh should have mentioned it oh I'm
gonna go run back and get that do you do
that thing I'll high-five you huh it's
like a run by high-five time I I feel
like the only like difficult weapons
might be like just charge charge blade
if you want the watcher
oh no skin for your palico you have to
so that's some time like February like
food or something like that like it says
how long it's active for so you still
have time to get that yeah Eloy skin
signing the game yet but they were gonna
have that in oh so the the bomber boy is
here this one I hate them so much he
just shows up anytime you're fighting
anything it's basically like nemesis
from Resident Evil 3 except right more
and then their music every time that
like
but it's real bad yeah I just want to
fight my my red dog in peace I may be my
new favorite comment is about like the
dark souls of IGN I'm gonna put that on
my business coma telly GameSpot's the
the blood borne of IGN put it out there
where the blood borne of ICN the gun
Lance is a good weapon for noobs I
haven't used the gun Lance very much so
I can't speak too much to it pretty good
its I feel like as long as you you pick
a weapon you think like it's cool and
you stick with it you'll be pretty well
off
there are tons and tons of guides
especially now coming out for specific
weapons where it'll be like a 45 minute
video where you have everything
explained to you and you'll you'll be an
expert as a training room you can access
from your room which is a really useful
way to get a feel for each weapon and
even you like some basic combos to
practice with not everything I guess
I'll be yeah like you said there were
videos that will just break it down for
you for like 45 minutes why would you do
that
they get real intense yeah that nari
ghonte and the elder dragon from one
with the beard I had that happen once
and it was frightening but I will try to
build up to everyone being like the
elder dragon zone I'm like middle of
fighting all of them right now did the
boy leave I think he did leave he's down
down over that way
the best way to get to this guy yeah I
think he went back to his his house ah
poisoned it's not what I wanted
everything's coming up not me all right
that's the only to find ya right
they're tough they're hidden tried three
stores today and they're all sold out
yeah people are jumping on the bus or on
a train wow that's actually kind of cool
yeah sorry you couldn't get a copy but I
mean that's cool at the games actually
we're watching I forget what it was like
a major TV event and then like a monster
hunter world commercial came out and I'm
like guys we did it
they're they're Monster Hunter
commercials on prime-time television
happening right now in front of me I'm
happy for Capcom I feel like they've
kind of had it rough yeah for a while
along with the yeah this actually worked
out for them oh shoot
okay yeah we we did it along with we
capture no all right now we kill them
yeah is it along with the the reports of
the sales for the caption oh really
yeah apparently I think it's just hunt
oh yeah but the along with the sales
numbers apparently this is the highest
capcom stock has been since like 2001
which is a thing Oh hot check now that's
good just all of it I didn't get my gym
I got to leave now go home I've been
I've been trying to get a jump for so
long just four days look at shiny
collector II can't believe this what's
which acts is that it's the explosive
affinity switch axe I'm not sure of the
name exactly but yeah we have a
beginner's guide up you can go check
actually that we have a bunch of hot
tips and we were thinking about maybe
doing an like
video follow up follow up if we get
enough extra tips to put in there
sources how do i kaio-ken in monster
hunter good question it's a very good
question I too would like to know how to
do that oh man I have items ready to
harvest bounties complete we may say we
can check out oh I should probably pick
up the rest of my my new bounty yeah if
you're in the game and you have a quest
that you've been struggling with we can
try to get some some some dudes on it
and we can back at you guys are killing
it let's get this research going let's
get sure bird withering research
progress in the round veil fine women
capture so yep someone is supposed to
the quest you can maybe go help them out
[Music]
look at all these these rad cards
I like these getting cards from people
awesome look at this this wonderful
group spectrum I feel a little bad for
trineo so you say that whose only level
3 but everyone else is uh doing well yes
tough to do we could we could join this
boy that will help him out with a tiny
thing what up epidemic looking good it's
found a strake hat oh but have you found
a Pookie and you found a put I want to
get the the Pookie outfits yeah yeah
sold out in stores you always by
digitally this is very true I hate how
much I love getting things digitally now
look at all the people here this game
especially so there are certain games
I'm just looking
I like having digital games where it's
the kind of game that I know I'll just
get in the mood for just turn on yeah
it's like Monster Hunter
is that kind of game that's like oh I
don't have to worry about getting the
disc out or anything just like I just
play monster on her it's great yeah yeah
definitely a special quests yeah maybe
wait on that one cuz that's just sort of
been like exploring the area yeah so we
might not join on that one it's mired in
the spire hunts Bharath barrel a level
three bear off we could join them I'm
worried we're just gonna like obliterate
it experience see I should switch up my
weapon to something different I'm going
to try
[Music]
should I try my charge blade I've been
trying to learn it I don't want to
embarrass myself do you guys give
talking about like a like a one to ten
kind of thing 1 to 10 score personally I
personally I would I would say maybe
like a 9 out of 10 from me
cuz it it's not perfect and I can admit
to that even with as much as I love it
but also it's really hard for me to say
like a game is perfect because in my
mind like a tennis I like this we've got
a whole community hanging out this is
this everything's coming up exactly I'm
kind of when we get some some good
assigned quests we're here let's do this
this was up before yeah let's help Dan
out we'll help Dan out here mmm sweet
all right Dan we're coming all right I'm
gonna use you know what since this is a
lower ranked quest I'm gonna I'm gonna
feel better about trying to mess around
with the the charge blade so I'll put
the charge bowl you wanna you wanna see
you want to get to the part where we
don't actually help because we both
don't know what we're doing
are you sure let's see like the bow or
something but would be a good time
I did just upgrade my bow I've been
trying to do some blow up great it's a
see it's a good I don't know if I got
that far in it though actually no this
is pretty good though no chatter we were
eating yeah we we can see both chats
we've got both chat technology available
so all chats all chats everywhere okay
let's see here
I'm gonna craft some nobody uses the
gathering help they should make the
whole lobby avatar visible yeah I I
agree too just like maybe even replace
the random NPCs walking around with
people I I thought it was a person but
it's not bi
I kind of agree all right dude get that
shower it's very high-tech goob we don't
mess around over here at GameSpot
headquarters in San Francisco California
with our dual chat technology cars I
went back to dual blade spam dude dual
blade spam is a plus you guys want to do
kuren we could hit up a Kirin I'd be
into it oh I did I did a carrion the
other day
yeah right the first time and that was a
cool fight I like it because it's
there's a beer named after it in Japan
that's delicious and also or like a
energy drink yeah right you drink that
makes burrito vs. monster hot ready to
go is that is that a call-out cyborg Man
2 - Gianluca knives unboxing burrito vs.
monster hunter I know that was pretty
good yeah right you were having a good
we actually had to tell you to stop
while we were filming he just kept
eating it we wouldn't have any more
burritos yeah that's not a goof for the
video but I was actually eating but yeah
actually if have any you guys actually
seen these these new style videos we're
doing you should let us know
yeah like the conversation video the
more kind of like relaxed unboxing video
or yeah maybe I saw a couple complaints
about the the unboxing one which is fair
because I think the unboxing one I think
some people just want it to be a little
more yeah like just just give it to me
straight
what's in this box wait what's in the
box if it doesn't really make sense for
unboxing we won't you know we're just
kind of experimenting with different
styles but people seem to like the other
one quite a bit actually
yeah I I really enjoyed filming that
conversation I thought it was a it was a
fun conversation AB oh god okay it was
funny alright man thought it was funny
so I'm glad you're in I'm gonna say
we're only gonna do unboxing that way
from now on yeah there we go it's always
with a burrito every single time the
same burrito from the same place okay
everyone get that sweet slide he makes
to armor parts and the game to make one
armor part like too far that I don't
think you can mix that necessarily just
because the way that the armor sets work
it's like each set is from a different
monster so you have to like say I want
to get this lag Jana set I have to kill
exclusively them so you can't like take
parts from a rathalos to switch it over
I don't know if that answers your
question but because everything's kind
of that kind of setup
hello panini does though the insect
glaive maybe a longsword retros are two
of my favorite weapons I'm a big fan I
used to think I was a long sword boy
exclusively and I really like the insect
glaive when they've put it in a little
while ago man I'm trying to expand my
horizons though I'm trying to learn how
to play other weapon types I'm about to
embarrass myself with a charge blade for
you guys if I die definitely switch to
something I know yeah if we had with you
copy since we have some high-level stuff
already yeah we kind of heard a couple
weeks yeah in advance
no people are catching up fast yeah they
are starting to feel there are people
who are who are dedicated they're very
into this and I love the fact that
that's a thing because that means we can
have people already do high ranks up
with us anyway yeah but also I kind of
like I was a little worried we weren't
we weren't gonna be able to do too much
high rank stuff yeah also I'm nice
whoever did that well I'm really into
the fact that we also are doing like not
necessarily hiring stuff but just
helping people out yeah all right so I
need to load this up I did an extra
swing that's fine this is the actual
story thing right I believe so okay
that's a yeah well you get parts and you
can use those to build up other weapons
me actually is a weapon I would like to
maybe craft if I think about this yeah
they're the weapons for this one
specifically are really cool there's
actually a dual blade for Kiran
wow that looked really really cool
also I just finally unlocked the ability
to send my safari I think you can
oh nice I locked the high-ranked once
you can do now so those are those are
real nice to eat the little bit of I can
illustrate some hiring stuff although
apparently you still need to fight that
monster at least once in high rank for
them to then go out and do it
so exciti like go back and make sure i
refight every this did this put it into
my shield come back yeah load it up and
now I'm set to go so I really wanted to
I would do this and then do this okay
yep that the high damage in yeah that's
the problem with the arrows you do good
there ii who aggro them here in trouble
and then we'll go again one more time
that wasn't as good a hit I'm still
trying to get like the positioning and
stuff down on this yeah we've got the
mechanics there's a lot of timing I was
watching some videos about how to use it
and a lot of the combos are based on
just like button times yeah
I'm still trying to get that amount oh I
didn't pay attention the fact that nice
thanks for hanging out yeah tell your
friends about my Monday absolutely you
can
200% it's a little weird because you'd
think the game kind of makes me think
it's online only because it always asks
you to either join or create a like
online session yeah but if you are
offline
it just says oh you can't play online
and it just automatically you can create
certain online so it's kind of weird
because they eat the menus kind of make
you think you have to play mine totally
that's the stuff that's what I want
yes that's that is that awesome charge
blade you get a sharpening going on no
Barry can get rid of the ice fact that's
true
I actually have them in my inventory
specifically yeah this too so part of
the the reason why I didn't do it I
think is because the the mic is like
covering up my stamina bar oh you can't
see so I've got like the microphone like
right in front of me but I can still see
the ice on my body I have no excuse I'm
afraid to eat my no berries see here
no oh boy he's on me she got that that
high-threat knows what you're up to
well you guys are all doing like you're
slower heads and I could just constantly
Pelt in I'm so cold
Oh got that the insurance so good it
happens like I did not know this
apparently you can change your online
like what your character says yes that
when you die to whatever you want
mm-hmm I need to do that I need to like
build a custom like what I died I wanted
to auto-generate like an excuse Sun was
in my eyes I couldn't see will over in
the UK said he was changing all of his
tags to be like different vine yeah
baseball slide it's so good come on
don't do this
photos high damage but it actually has
pretty limited and the vials I can use
with it so I definitely need that it's
understandable
she changed I blame tape for every
single thing that happens sure oh that's
that's pretty good i I've never really
messed with the mess there are the
messages very much that it actually
sounds like a really cool thing to do
Oh like if I die just say like blame
hashtag blames hey there you go yeah
that's real good I get six each time so
we're getting some some crafting info in
here too oh yeah that seems like a good
one maybe I should do if I want to go in
on the bow I should maybe start
cultivating stuff for like different
coating coatings seems like the good way
to go
the a good starting thing is just use a
honey honey herbs and you can just
stockpile making potions I have so many
mega potions I can make that I actually
was like oh I'm good I should start
crafting some other stuff I have to say
though I have been kind of like going
into these later like elder dragon
fights I've been been leaing real hard
into those potions and it's it's been
putting a big dent in my problem is you
can only put like ten at a time yeah
Nega nutrients also a good one I
recommend yeah because when you lose
that inevitably lose your meal bonus
from dying
exactly way to get health back up Jack
this is a rathalos like a high-level
Rathalos charge blade that looks cool
yeah I like it's just it's just a big
dumb face do it Dan do it light him up
Dan's also got a bow I didn't realize
your boy missed
it was very embarrassed
you get out of wherever I am
get back here I'm not done with you oh
my god so that's the biggest problem for
me I think is I'm not used to the range
on this which is a weird excuse because
you can totally switch it to like the
axe mode but from what I understand you
have to spend a lot of time not in axe
mode no this time around
yikes
come back I just want to hit you a bunch
yeah right in the face there we go now
he's mad whoop-whoop hit him hit him hit
him yes that going get this going
fill this up Oh God come on he's so
close get down from there
oh you moved still got some some good
voice though I guess I can't wait for
the the PC version - I'm excited
oh come on
oh it's not gonna pay much attention to
the chat we're kind of there you go
no now we're back ah that was good
god help that guy out yeah so again if
you want you can you can join up we've
got the session ID down below the
picture got a good amount of people in
here already but we still got plenty of
room get the max I think it's sixteen
okay
but yeah post up a quest if we see some
some cool things you guys need help with
we can jump in and help because we're
way leveled up because we're we've been
playing for a while
we're gonna try to build towards maybe
at the end of the stream trying to get a
stab in there gigante if you want to so
you want to do that this time yeah so we
could go fight them yeah spoilers we are
gonna maybe check out the endgame area
yeah so we might run into that you might
might see if expert likes to crash crap
when you mess I might have to leave it
hopefully it'll be darker when we get
into the other area I don't know okay oh
man you're running a dangerous risk guys
if we disappear I'm so sorry I'll miss
you we'll be back okay so far away it's
so far away
shadows are cool
hmm oh my tracking whiz like dual blades
and charge blender your favorite I'm
still trying to wrap my mind around
charge of blade I want to use it cuz it
looks so cool we got it
I can get you right now
apologies it's all good is there G rank
in this game not yeah you got a plate
why do you have so much luck with all
these drops I can't deal with this
fishing can make a lot of nice so
apparently the way to make money is with
the bandit mantle in that whenever it
drops stuff I didn't realize this but
all the things that it drops are just
meant for selling there was it was I
think it wasn't for where you could
dress up calico like Dante so I think
towards the back we've got all these
things you can just sell yeah trading
items and it just drops a whole bunch of
things that you can just sell for money
I've got 30 of these for a thousand so
that's thirty thousand are those for
selling yeah we've got 20 of these for
2,000 be out there just for selling oh I
haven't touched that at all I should
probably go one of these for 5k I just
haven't sold them and I didn't even
realize it was a thing at all nice armor
thank you it's it's one of my favorite
sets so I have this and I'm going to try
to change my equipment here maybe I'll
try a dual blade at least plate oh I'll
put these on and I'll use these
depending on what what quest we're doing
alright I'm gonna switch back to my good
old dual blades try sown in the chats
they dual blades are awesome and you're
correct sir they are they're a pretty
good time
try charged blade master on forbidden
grass me as much of the insect leave did
that's exactly what happened to me
retros alright I mean just
double-checking my bounties
sounds like a plan yeah I do have one
okay so what do we got going west give
me a sec we're gonna fight uh creature
oohs ah the Oregon I might not use I
might not use the dual blades for this I
might oh no I'm
is it oh can i connect to the server
oh no it's okay well I think you're
still in I'm still in though weird I've
never seen that before
let me try more time that's as soon as I
knew that's a new one for me
yeah do psn was having real rough try
ghost right again
I love the Zorro armor - I I could show
you guys the new sets that I unlocked
but I don't know if I want to spoil any
how's the weird little hiccup level 12
lobsters join the online session my
favorite type of lobster all right it
was an optional quest right yes all
right I got a squad invite the or eating
occupier I'll maybe check that out later
means let's go
wow we got a good amount of people in
here this is a this is a good time look
it look at all these people hanging out
and this is cool look some people are
like maybe teamed up already yeah and
like I said if you guys are in here
definitely like play with each other if
we're not with you or join up with us if
you can
fair warning we're about to check out
the final area in the game so if you
don't want to see it oh yeah spoiler
warning I am good to asking what skin is
that are they referring to your skin I
the the armor that I'm wearing is like
80% from the auto gamma which is
you're fighting it earlier where it's
it's like like a red I hate calling it
like a skinless dog but that's the only
thing I can think of calling it you
fight him in the rotten Vale and it's
really cool armor that it gives you
bleeding resistance fire resistance and
it also basically helps kind of we got
off a whole crew a whole crew I love it
gonna change the prep yeah yeah back on
my charge blade nonsense I don't trust
this is gonna be an actual fight
very few lance players same I feel like
a lot of people are kind of gravitating
towards the same things which is why I
I'm trying to make as many weapon types
as I can so I can learn other stuff and
I feel like the weapon tree definitely
helps kind of make me feel like I can do
that a lot better but I like I like
trying out doing things we did it so
maybe I'll maybe before monster hunter
Mondays next week I'll learn how to use
a lance a little bit and totally mix it
up I want to see light bogan and heavy
yeah I like the light bogan more than
the heavy I think but then I
automatically think about the heavy gun
and how it has the like just lay into
something button yeah the only one has
it yeah the only one doesn't have it to
that degree I think the heavy you can
also do like those artillery strikes we
have pretty cool have you both guns real
nice oh no all right I got I got landed
stranded in the wrong place how come I
don't know that's weird why did it do
that I had to drink my cool drink though
it got real intense I need to make those
should have some inside of the box but
yeah some chill shrooms around that you
can turn them into into cool dry I found
him you know maybe just put you have you
a brush because of the tracking you
tracked him enough it'll just kind of
put you there sometimes which is cool
yeah so he's he's down here hanging out
that's do it oh you're here - siren
wails - no just the music play when you
cook the meat like a monster for you yes
does it's not as there isn't as much to
it it's a little bit quicker but it's
it's there I really struggle with the
timing of that for whatever reason yeah
I it's not the same and that's what
really messed with me but well I'm in
the fire No
oh yeah we can lure him out of here that
would actually be would be really nice
so this boy he's got fire rocks that he
shoots out of his tail Wow right on top
of me you know I'm gonna walk this way
yeah if he comes over here we have
anything to lure him he doesn't want to
play that game he wants it you're there
he goes yes yes yes oh my goodness I'm a
heel really quick don't run away
Jean oh dude you were you're so close
you know what just kind of find out that
must get real warm
oh no I like fighting him a lot that
guy's not actually that hard yeah oh got
stuck in a hole Oh
pitfall trap nice nice nice do it up hit
him
this this is the stuff that's that's how
you do it this reminds me of Chris
punching folder yeah actually in the
volcano in five I can see it my top
top-down video game moments it's so
weird he went from how he was Resident
Evil's a wacky time yeah
Resident Evil's treatment of its
characters very oh man
I'm trying to find a point where they
say if and I'm like no I just think it's
kind of I don't think they do a great
job between games they keep changing
voice actors to keep changing characters
too much yeah at least in English
versions and it's just like through I
feel like there's very little
consistency but God do I love them no
but yeah I say this out of love for all
things Resident Evil I complain cuz I
can I just got hit hard yeah you did Wow
okay he's just going into the lava more
not less and I don't like that oh my god
you know I don't know if I knocked him
out of that I'm gonna say I did but I
know it's not true might have been me I
don't know I do have poison blade got
more traps set up bring him on over yeah
oh yeah I got I've wasted that entire
whoa who hit me here you and then I got
hit by something what is happening oh
dude this is going bad what is something
just shot me out of nowhere though like
with a fireball
we're probably gonna fail this what is
okay okay I'm gonna I'm gonna refocus up
here I just got blindsided oh is it the
lava snake of course it's a lot of snake
what the the like lava snake dude also
hangs out here and he just pops out and
like shoots fireballs at you well don't
worry they are guys left that's good
bouncing I don't think have any
nutrients or anything so I might have to
like kind of rough it for a bit okay I'm
installed we're done 100 hours in a
monster owner and and then we get
blindsided by a fireball or days we're
done we're out I want to take a cool
drink just to do it I don't know if
we're all very nervous now oh I'm super
nervous I mean we're not very far into
the fight and already
I don't have my I don't have my I'm
waiting for that you can eat again
message to pop up
a breaking ball breaking parts that's
good that's good oh honey really quick
dog he wants she wants to knock you out
for sure not cool dude no no no he's
coming after me well this is not where I
wanted to be at all it's a waste of a
mega potion but that's fine
more like oh you mounted him nice but he
did good
yes yes that was the the first thing I
thought about but I don't have any any
nutrients I should start farming some
yes they end up being a big thing you
need a broader craft for making
nutrients yeah very useful come down I'm
still on he's doing it here comes yes oh
yes - do it again
cuz of course you can do it again it's
done now dude I haven't hit him since I
came back there we go part heart broken
reduced okay ow no no not the tail
they're mine there's just another part
those little dudes need to go away they
are actually annoying
no don't be here this is a bad place to
be ah nice it's a good flash over did
that what up Benjamin how's it going
don't die don't be the guy don't do it
please
all right
it's a bomb hayloft I came completely
unprepared for this I think there's the
tail tail
don't try and carve it don't don't
gamble
no I'm not about not about that life
right now not about this life either I
fell over look at him
you sound such a hard time
random on this thing
I don't know why I don't like it
what no he's good let's good get the
tail that's good buzz gonna grab on to
him and ride him out need help finding a
monster which one you're looking for
black star getting shadow Colossus
remake that's a good call that game is
still really good and it's just more
pretty now okay whoop here he is
we thought we were gonna find him he's
the one who found us that's the first
time I've ever been hit directly by one
of the like rocks as he shot them out
how're we doing right feel pretty good
feel like we're doing all right it's
very nervous yeah
same well I can eat again
I might cuz they're all careful oh my
god please don't please don't
when he does the rolling it's all right
I'm gonna try to run out to get
something because there's a camp right
up here okay I'll be back in a second
though it's because I want to be
absolutely sure everything's gonna be
okay yes unless you guys gonna get that
murder on him oh no that's opposite of
wants to have happen that boy showed up
again Basile guys just showed up we're
in trouble
I'm not not real excited about that yeah
go go for it yeah okay
you got yeah more going on right now
this is bad well switch back to yours
once cuz I did not set mine up with the
idea okay
do-do-do-do yeah this is what I want
okay I just I'm just kind of staying out
of the way at the moment cuz yeah I
wouldn't the other two dudes are as well
I I wouldn't Joe nobody wants to die let
someone do enough damage to someone else
until they decide to run away that's
kind of where I am pretty much Oh guys
get out of there get out of there oh
okay
just got started here and tried to fight
the engine ass that's that's that
dangerous stuff man
Angelina doesn't mess around especially
likely when you're first starting out oh
yeah you get out of there you got it
oh okay I'm okay I'm okay steel okay
there the other guy just left oh wait do
you have your your audio muted what for
your your thing how you can switch back
to mine if you want
oh we do I apologize I was like oh yeah
you know why it's because I have it
plugged in oh that would do it sorry
about that guys
I forgot that I have my headphones
plugged in directly to my controller
which removes it I hate that it does
that there should be a way to say a put
everywhere which Xbox does but sorry
about that
yikes no and those those clutch clutch
heels coming in oh you got that the
amount again hell yeah do it do that
mount
oh I can still do that while he's
mounting him that's awesome oh nice
you get him there's there's all this
damage happening us oh boy
broken part ride him into the wall oh my
god knock him down go mess him up mess
him up
[Music]
there's so many choice of rocks
everywhere he's all he's all poisoning
everything all those parts are broken
he's he's hurt and she's running away
nope yep looks just go into that that
kind of sloppy area at the beginning so
I we can do is without trap so your
traps have been real clutch first time
he open his mouth I was like I'll go
somewhere else
I yeah that's uh it's about how how you
feel I think generally he's uh he means
business
oh I think he's coming back no he's he's
fighting his fight here oh I see I see
was he on him we've got that that really
great stunts which acts going on he was
limping my body no so we don't have a
trap I don't think we have any more
traps I should start building some got
bombs nice capture yeah can we do a
capture a prop project capture look at
those bombs hey who wants to hit it
yowza nice get over here next to the
trap girls use traps strap throw and
tricks just like that another another
expert monster captured by our viewers
carrying us through thank you guys that
was really intense I was so nervous that
entire fight was probably the most
intense might have done in a while but
fantastic work tenacious and takari holy
cow see that I mean I made my tweet
talking about the show definitely like
come and tell us about how your your
weekend hunts went and also carry us
through everything
man that was that was real good Wow
well is a word but yeah three gems can't
out of here
stop I'm not even using my vouchers I'm
stopping I haven't seen a gem in like 30
hours of playing dude I think I might be
able to do near Gurgaon say
really I think I'm gonna go check we
might we might get to do this this might
be the the time that would be the good
thing that in the stream on actually
apparently the lobby is not coming back
was mentioned in previous stream last
week I believe you can talk about that
yeah so we decided to I guess shut now
Milad be after almost I think it's like
been four years it's been going on for
yeah and yeah we just felt like it
wasn't working as well as it could have
you know like it was time was it is kind
of time to put it to rest
we really appreciate everyone who did
love watching the lobby and we're sad to
see it go that was really nice to see
but yeah we're it doesn't mean we're in
trouble or anything like that we're just
trying some new stuff out to see what
works an example that would be that
Monster Hunter conversation that you
mean Peter had yeah as an idea of a kind
of new way to talk about games a new
format for us so yeah just kind of
keeping out for that kind of stuff where
we're trying out new things well see
we've been rocking with approached
anxious says that they've been playing
since monster homers on the ps2 so we're
in good hands okay when is this game
coming out on PC later this year is
about all we know I think I don't I
don't think we've given us like a date
or anything okay speak to the commander
yeah I think you are actually we might
this might be the near gigante fight
this is the run back the saltiest run
back because we couldn't beat him in the
beta on the show slated for July or
August so yeah that would make sense
like a summer release somewhere around
there
right
[Music]
I'm gonna head up to the gathering hub
again okay I'm just gonna go get this
quest yeah I'm still I'm still kind of
like half shaking from that whole the
whole experience cuz I was really
expecting me to be the person to ruin it
yeah me too
I'm not was expecting you I was
expecting myself to ruin ya how big
flying monster that's on fire SOS please
help me trying to think of the flying
monster that's on fire it might be that
one that we've been talking about
causing a cousin a ruckus unfortunately
what you want to try to do true but uh
if anyone else is around please go help
our friend lucky star oh yeah there are
three different rooms that you can hang
out in but ya eat my food real quick
what do you guys think about state of
decay - I'm excited it should be a good
time you see here you get excited about
[Music]
this yeah right it's it's a mental thing
like it I I'm gonna prepare you guys you
know we might not make this I think so
okay so just be ready it you you find
him pretty quick though okay
[Music]
everytime you capture monster then shows
up in this we've got a wonderful pals of
starting up on their ghonte fight ooh
I don't know if it'll count for you
theoretically it should but I'm just
gonna start this quest up for myself oh
there are rumors apparently making a new
Prince of Persia game it's exciting oh
really man so I get really excited
whenever they're like we're bringing
back to France am i cool but that seemed
I guess I got a I gotta make a history
of on that probably here we go okay time
to go play every I actually really liked
I don't remember what year it was it was
like 2008 or 2009 like that weird
cel-shaded one I like the 2081 I enjoyed
it I liked it'll have a defender of the
2008 principle yeah let's see it went in
a thirst I toggle the lucky voucher dude
it'll double your money for a lot I
consumption you I mean we'll probably
fail but I'm okay alright yeah I'm gonna
have to wait until you've watched the
cutscene okay so Joyce
who's currently in the session I'll go
look at some of the armor sets that I've
got if anyone wants to check those out
oh you actually do that because we're
not too worried about me trying to like
kill anything you guys have audio sorry
about that last time we're you didn't
mine okay
and we're doing it drops explode and
when I kill yep that's that's the one
he's a real pain we I still compare him
to like nemesis from from Resident Evil
three I don't like him at all you don't
fight him until like two two ranks later
just real real weird but he just run
away from them
don't even mess with them save yourself
all right man yeah I'm wondering if I
should use she used my insect glaive
because I like using it a lot for this
fight because he likes to fly around a
lot I love when you do these elder
dragon fights and all the other monsters
disappear yeah
setting the mood also like different
effects happen in the sky inside like
here in one and there was like lightning
and it felt very ominous in a way that
was cool yeah yeah we're definitely
fighting him in front of this crystal oh
man I totally forgot about deep down oh
yeah they showed that during the
original PlayStation 4 like revealed
yeah and we still don't have it yet yeah
watching this cutscene
Judah's freaked out
I mean rightfully so
oh boy you feeling it cuz I'm feeling it
I'm not even there yet I'm nervous
yikes
get ready they're ready to join alright
okay run
alright I'm gonna join as soon as I get
get in here okay what is your you're
going right in
you're not even messing around I got a
feeling out of it like feel out what to
do God that music is so good the music
in this game is just good in general but
God okay what are we doing here no I
want to go post up a quest dude you got
this alright just hold on we're on the
way join me we're on the way we're doing
it oh cool we got we got people we're
doing it were doing it I should have
made some some armor armor potion that
would've been good I already eat I got
too excited I think I already ate check
check
I already date I get on in here that's
what blades I'm using I'm just using the
iron blades damage alright I'm on my way
I'm trying to build up some I don't know
what he's weak too but I think he is
actually like super susceptible to
poisons oh then you know I'm rocking the
right equipment here at least that's
what would people were saying a bit ago
why would you dump me here every time
okay we still got room for nope yep
tenacious join - thank you we got full
party
oh okay I feel like with our boys
tenacious in Hakkari we've got this on
we got a good chance
no he's right behind you I got this
yellow bar no no you couldn't even see
the green it was it was non-existent
that was rough
okay okay I'm going to I'm gonna swap
over back to you okay oh there's that
they were you knock again all right
they're on you because I'm
so keep watching typing
oh yeah
what up happy Phil it's true your name
is Phil my internet name is Phil there's
a lot of a lot of bills happening I love
it
ooh there we go get them out
come on come on how's it going we're
we're enough liquor it oh god Wow okay
we go get that that / flurry on the tail
there you go ah one of the ways get out
of here
all right scam online only are offline
as well it is entirely offline if you
want it to be the game is entirely solo
able but it's definitely enhanced if
you're playing with your pals I didn't
bring any any vitality or any of those
things unfortunately I probably should
have grabbed something before I will
hands
yeah I like it because I can use it to
avoid a lot and then I get really scared
anytime you took like four ears up
there's one hit kill or you know that
ideally if I could get away from it I
weren't bad in the weird crystal area
where you started off okay we got that
stun
yeah no one else has died yet they're
right not yet no Mary guys are
whoa he's uh don't don't follow me
stop
that's nice nice break this stuff up as
best I can
Oh hips
I like this area a lot better to find a
minute a lot of hills yeah right okay
didn't get hit somehow he hasn't done is
his one-shot move yet and I'm really
worried about it cuz I'm 200% gonna be
the guy who watches it
Oh hit me middle come on
[Music]
whoo nice doing them hits just the hips
yeah he's gotta be close holy cow I feel
like you guys have done all the work for
me I feel bad now
real talk again it's it's tenacious and
card who or who are you definitely carry
me carry us right I'll probably go back
and do this fight on my own at some
point oh you definitely a lot of the
higher-end armor requires no there's not
there is a heartbeat monitor you can see
though let's to the mini-map that's kind
of how you get like a
not it not it no no Roy we're all good
he's running away good
tenacious my dude he was close guys we
made it somehow we made it oh good
there's a healing okay you drop any I
saw a couple random ones go that's a
strategy and communication happening
right now
tenacious and Hikari are talking about
strategies and how best to use some
items we've got flash pods and just like
that oh your boy is you have got him
nice
Oh Kinmen head yep that could have gone
really bad for me I totally know I use
this little lip to try and get on him I
wasted that that health potion I don't
know why I did that
don't don't kill me please no please
save by the get off you there yeah
ride him tenacious to it oh he's also
got this arm a go
okay
knock-down he's a very angry boy right
now I think he's still got some time cuz
his legs tied to his his spines or
whatever I missed just beating myself
like ten minutes to go it's it's a heck
of a fight I do like how the first
couple Monster Hunter betas were like
here's kind of what Monster Hunters like
and then the last one was like here's
NER he God say welcome to Monster Hunter
you idiots but then you watch people do
it oh yeah they're good it's all good
one more faint guys there was everyone
avoid it I think so I think we're good
we're good
ooh
those dragon pods we should have had
like like proper headsets plugged in to
like actually be able to talk incentive
on the delay what for yeah I stood to
kind of get the the good communication
going but he's so low he's limping this
is all right he's on the ropes on the
ropes boys all right no one get cocky
about fly casual I like this I like
where this is going this is this is good
he's going back to his his home he's
probably gonna go to sleep all perfect
no you can't capture all the dragon oh
they do say that all the dragons are a
do-or-die situation at the time now she
got you wanna sleep you little spiny
baby look at him oh I got a barrel let
me put a barrel down Jean Luc's potent
one I can't talk it's okay I put it down
we're good all right so I'm going I can
like can I do up nope that doesn't work
I know we did it worked it hit him so
insects don't break barrels hot tip we
just learned
probably should've just grabbed this I
did put down when barrels comes fine you
didn't know that oh yeah
we go get in here it's on him now I
don't know I'm just
I'm trying trying to get them out
yeah oh he's got a lot of he's doing the
thing he got out of the way dude you did
it it's fine you try to get him off you
oh god no he's already done on me right
now
come on get on him no I have no stun
anything it's so close I just got hit by
the roof moving on to the tail if we can
okay oh there's a tail cut tail we've
got our health booster
but I must land upon that booster real
quick
Oh
stuck next to that thing
whoo thank you against Nations Hikari
for carrying the entire group ho buddy
guys that was awesome that was a real
ass hunt is what that was I need to yeah
see the chance to breathe here good
start I did that on the voucher I got a
gym so flipping it finally happened I
got a gem but it's not the gym I was
looking for feeling it I'm still feeling
it again I can't got the tail make sure
you get the tail yeah oh yeah that's
right God I'm I'm completely out of
everything the tail come off at got
enough time we're fine it's okay he's
not gonna look at the timer I'm just
happy we made it through the fight your
switch switch back over you yeah
I'm putting Japanese by the way nice I
think we still have my sound oh no no
those are our boys Thank You boys and
then the game just keeps going yeah yeah
so the ingame sound is low they still
low for you guys
we look off to the crystals into the
future of hunting more Elder Dragons
know it that crystal area reminds me of
um the crystal cave from Dark Souls 1 oh
and here's the the T's for for ghupat
boy whenever boy is talking about honey
very good my god
smells like someone's business in here
oh man ok grab all that good stuff is
that is that where we're was that we're
calling it for today is that it doesn't
feel like that at all
oh man so I guess in summary if you guys
enjoyed Monster Hunter Monday be sure to
come back next week where we will
continue to venture and hunt together
with you guys and yeah you can come hang
out would be a good time every Monday 11
o'clock I will be streaming again
tomorrow
so be sure to follow the channel you
notified whenever we go live subscribe
like don't miss a show I don't want to
miss a thing I don't want to miss you
keep it together I'm looking good thanks
guys thanks again yes same thanks again
for the help you guys is really good
hunts if you see play Monster Hunter
help someone out make sure you join us
next Monday for more Monster